okay so The Shining is one of my
favorite movies of all time depending on
what day it is the the top spot for me
switches between this the thing and also
the Godfather like those it's one of
those movies that stuck with me since
the first time I watched it I remember
being about eight years old scared out
of my mind after my first visit to the
Overlook but why does it have this long
lasting power and influence I mean on
the surface you could be forgiven for
thinking that the movie is extremely
simple as a kid I thought it was pretty
much about a family who were given the
job of looking after a hotel and the dad
went crazy and then tried to kill him
however there's so many layers to the
film and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down all the
subliminal ways that the movie messes
with you along with its hidden meanings
now the biggest head is the hotel itself
you might not know but King came up with
the idea for The Shining when visiting
the Stanley Hotel out in Boulder
Colorado he and his wife booked it
October 30th which was the night before
it was just about a close for the season
they were the only two guests there and
Kings spent the night wandering the long
hallways of the hotel swept up in just
how creepy a place like this could be if
it wasn't teeming with guests now the
name The Shining comes from the John
Lennon song Instant Karma
the idea that people imprinted onto
something long after they're gone is
what the overlooking bodies and it
seemingly filled with the souls of those
that it's trapped along the way
traumatic events leave long-lasting
Impressions and this is why it's teeming
with all sorts of evil spirits now it's
important to bear in mind that the hotel
is supposed to be its own malevolent
entity and it's very much alive when
watching the movie for this breakdown I
think two things became very clear and
that is that the hotel itself didn't
want jack it actually wanted Dany it
also became clear to me that Jack has
The Shining as well which is why he
didn't lose his going into room 237
now we will talk about whether the
ghosts are even real later on but taking
at face value I think Jack was the
easiest to manipulate and this is why it
sort him out the hotel wanted to get
Jack to kill Danny and this would be
able to take his immense power Dr sleep
also makes it clear that alcohol condol
lists Sixth Sense and in that we join an
elderly Danny Torrance who's hit the
bottle hard potentially Jack was an
alcoholic for the exact same reason and
his months of sobriety ended up cracking
him enough to the point that he could
pick up the presence of the spirits
should have hit the spirits hey
interestingly there's this weird
inconsistency in the movie where Jack
says that he hit Danny three years ago
which is when he promised to stop
drinking however he also says here's to
five miserable months on the wagon this
implies that he kept drinking secretly
and it was only his time in the hotel I
cut him off from it completely makes
into anything about it too as Jack only
started to see the ghost deep into the
winter and this time completely away
from alcohol likely start up his senses
in the end though Jack ends up perishing
we get that horning photo of him on the
wall at the July 4th ball in 1921 bring
up this photo in full we can see that
he's doing a pose with his right arm
angled upwards and is left on pointing
down this actually has links to Satanism
and when searching satanic poses on
Google the first result that comes up is
Baphomet doing the exact same thing it's
really chilling and the ending of the
movie is something that stuck with me
for decades now in discussing it
keebrick suggested that this could hint
at their Bing reincarnation within the
hotel and certain aspects of the film
definitely seem to suggest this for
example we hear this story of Charles
Grady who killed his whole family my
predecessor and his job heard a man
named Charles Grady is the winter
caretaker and he came up here with his
wife with two little girls who think
about eight and ten and he had a good
employment record good references and
from what I've been told I mean he
seemed like a completely normal
individual but at some point during the
winter he must have suffered some kind
of a complete mental breakdown he ran a
muck and uh
killed his family with an ax now the
important thing to bear in mind here is
the name Charles Grady and the fact that
his daughters were 8 and 10. we of
course seem to meet these as they
terrified Dany but these are clearly
Twins and not sisters born at different
times later on in the bathroom we also
meet a man going by Grady who killed his
family with an ax but he clearly says
that his name is dalbot well they call
you around here Jeezy great is a Delbert
Grady this could show that there were
two greaties at the hotel that matter
their family and that they were
reincarnations of each other in the time
between them dying and them having to
grow up the other one could have filled
in and continued the cycle and this is
why we have these errors in the name
this would also explain the line you've
always been the caretaker
foreign
I've always been here I would also
explain why Jack says he feels like he
has deja vu
I came up here for my interview
it was as though
I'd been here before
I mean we all have moments of deja vu
but this was ridiculous there's also the
idea that the twins want Danny to stay
forever and ever and ever now in
crafting the novel King said that time
doesn't really exist in the hotel and
this is how all the different decades
seem to happen at the same time on top
of this there was an alternative ending
that containedly had seen that changed
the way that the movie plays out in it
Danny and when you were in the hospital
and they were visited by Mr Ullman he
said that none of the skeletons or
rivers of blood were there when they
inspected the hotel that it must have
been because of their imaginations
however he gives Danny a tennis ball
which is the same one that rolled
towards him from room 237 and the name
Overlook 2 has its own secret meaning
though it could be taken as meaning that
it's overlooking the mountain range it
could also be taken as meaning to
overlook something we as the audience
aren't seeing what's really going on in
there and there's also the idea that
swimming in the hotel is looking over
the those inside Stanley Kubrick used a
Steadicam technique throughout and this
was a revolutionary way of filming at
the time it allows you to follow the
characters through the hotel and we get
shots like this at several points giving
the feeling that both Us in the hotel
are stalking the family a huge shout out
to Rob Asia for budding together several
videos on the film and in those he
talked about how the layout of it was
actually impossible several people in
the modding Community try to rebuild the
Overlook in the Duke Nuka map but they
found that when trying to recreate it
they just couldn't do it without
breaking the layout itself most of the
rooms overlap and there's several
doorways in Windows that actually lead
to nothing for example just before Jack
walks into Mr ullman's office we can see
there's a large hallway that runs down
the back behind it upon entering the
office though we can see that there's a
window directly behind elman's office
that shows trees this view simply
doesn't exist and subconsciously this is
flagging up to us in the back of our
minds there's also the bike ride that
Danny takes and this happens just after
the Tuesday chapter card pops up on
screen now it's important about in mind
that this all takes place on the second
floor which we know because Danny rides
past the balcony twice and we can see
into the main hall as we start off we
have an Elevator Shaft to the left and
then an open door with a set of stairs
on the right we then follow Danny at the
corridor and watch as he turns left on
the right we can see another set of
elevator doors and these link to the
ones in the main hall just below this
which we see in later shots now this
makes the previous pair impossible as
the wall where the Elevator Shaft should
be is actually the wall in the hall that
has the Native American art on it the
elevator behind it simply wouldn't fade
and the open stairwell would also lead
to Nowhere now let's go back to those
elevator doors next to the balcony and
as Dany continues to ride we see that on
the left there is a place to look out
over the main hall as we follow Dany he
turns right
and then right and then write again and
this time we can catch him riding past
the balcony once more this is impossible
as it would mean that he's turned back
on himself and he would be above the
Colorado Lounge now look at the
thickness of the wall just beside the
balcony we can see that it's about a
meter and a half wide and yet down the
hallway we see several doors lining that
side leading to Rooms that's simply
aren't there now this cardo also
contains room 237 later on when Dany
approaches this we can see doors to the
other rooms lining the walls beside it
what about when we go into room 237 and
see how big it is we know that these
doors don't actually lead anywhere as
they back right into the room itself
when almond is showing the torrents is
around just before they get to their
room we can also see a door down the
back and one to the right due to where
the bedroom and bathroom are we also
know that this doesn't lead anywhere and
the window outside that leads to the
snow slide also shows at the door down
the bottom of the corridor doesn't go
anywhere either something just feels up
about the hotel itself and all these
things add to its Mystique plus there's
the fact that it's so brightly lit like
how many other horror movies can you
name that are this bright and it
actually feels unnatural to have
something like this it's also the fact
that every room in the hotel feels
different and we never really get a
sense of place because we never know
what the characters are walking into now
if you've seen the documentary room 237
then you'll know there's lots of
conspiracy theories surrounding the
movie This covers things like Kubrick
being the guy who faked the moon landing
because of the Apollo 11 jumper the
movie being a metaphor for the genocide
of Native Americans and even the
Holocaust I think with The Shining that
some of these ideas can definitely be
found in here but the incomplete and
thus never fully formed because of this
people can grasp at them and run off
with their imagination which is another
reason that people keep talking about
the movie according to the now playing
podcast when Tom Cruise was making Eyes
Wide Shut he would see Kubrick still
cutting and editing The Shining in his
bed time to me that says that the movie
was never really finished and because of
this there's these half ideas formed
throughout now the Holocaust idea links
to the fact that Jack uses another
typewriter this also changes color
throughout the movie going from Light
tan to a gray blue due to its use in the
Holocaust to take people's names before
they were shipped off to the ghetto and
concentration camps many of the eurizer
that symbolizes this dark event in
history the color change could
potentially also show the darkness
sweeping over the hotel it's interesting
how this Alters throughout now I'm not
sure how much Merit there is to it as
it's the same model of typewriter that
Kubrick used and he said in an interview
that he he just liked using it now the
character Jag was also very much a
Stephen King's standing and this
frustrated writer felt creatively
bankrupt much like how Kubrick may have
felt at the time so this typewriter
could just be referenced to himself and
him feeling like he's typing away and
getting nothing done as we mentioned
there's also the Native American
genocide which I think holds far far
more weight and almond is showing the
family around he talks about the hotel
itself and he says construction started
in 1907. it's finished in 1909. the site
is supposed to be located on an Indian
burial ground and I believe they
actually had to repel a few in attacks
as they were building it he also
mentions the Native American Art in the
Colorado Lounge are all these Indian
designs authentic yeah I believe the
base mainly on Navajo and uh Patrick
motifs there are theories that the
Elevator Shaft itself leads directly on
the ground and when building the hotel
itself they had to shift corpses out the
way this is what the river of blood
could symbolize and it's bringing
everything up buried beneath the surface
there's also the music at the start
which has whaling over the top of it
foreign
American chants this could be hinting at
what's really going on now throughout
the hotel we also have several pictures
that signify this for example when
Jack's about to enter Mr ullman's office
we see a painting to his left and this
is called the great mother there's also
several paintings of Native Americans
throughout the hotel and these pop up as
the family gets shown about when we get
to the fridge and Dick Halloran is
talking away we can also see some food
with a prominent Native American figure
on it Wendy later on wears yellow coat
with Native American images on it and
there's also the tapestry in the main
hall itself Jack constantly throws a
ball at this and he ends up chucking
this in a way that similar to the ax
motion he makes when cutting down the
door when drinking at the bar Jack also
says White Man's Burden Lloyd my man
white man's bird and many have theorized
this is referring to white guilt again
there's so many theories on this film
and let me know your thoughts below now
we start off can you can you believe
that we're 12 minutes in 50 seconds into
the video and we haven't done the first
scene yet but we start off with Jack
driving through the mountains to his job
interview at the Overlook the footage
was actually used at the end of any cuts
of Blade Runner and the blue text
popping up is something Jordan Peele
also adopted for the start of get out
the similar scene also happens in the
sequel Dr sleep and I was gonna do all
the callbacks to that and this but we'll
end up with a two-hour video and I think
instead I might just cover that movie in
its own separate breakdown anyway over
the top of this we hear the dies here a
medley which spells Doom for the
torrances this ancient song is a bad
impending death and its notes are also
used at the beginning of A Clockwork
Orange
[Music]
Jack here is riding in a yellow Beetle
and later on Dick hollaram passes a
crushed red one in the snow this was
actually meant to be Kubrick making a
Jabba King because in the book Jack
drives a red one it's sort of cubic
saying we don't need your stuff we have
mine now in adapting the novel Kubrick
said that the shining isn't exactly a
literary Masterpiece and it's from here
that the uneasy rivalry kind of star
between the two the majority of
Kubrick's work adapted novels and these
often had mixed receptions but he was
able to take the elements that he liked
and craft them into something new I
actually like the book but this first
shot is probably what caused them to
start to dislike each other king had it
set up contractually that if the book
ever got adapted that he would get to
create the first draft for this script
but Kubrick ended up throwing this out
upon release King said he didn't really
like the movie The though over time he
said he has come to appreciate it he
actually ended up making his own Vision
in 1997 that he said was the true one
but the less sad about that is probably
the better now he approached the car
park and can count 42 cars parked by the
Overlook 42 is a number that later
appears on Danny's t-shirt in the
bathroom and when we later cut to the TV
scene we can catch them watching the
summer of 42. this TV also doesn't have
any electrical cables which adds an
extra head to the scene as it's not
plugged in also 42 million dollars is
later mentioned and this could also link
with a room 237 if you do two times
three times seven then you get 42 and as
I've been saying it's all connected now
why could this be well again tying back
to the Holocaust Theory 1942 is the year
that the final solution was put in place
and it could Kirby kibrick hinting to
that Jack then goes into Mr Holman's
office and this room is perfectly
recreated in doctor's sleep on Allman's
desk when we flip around we can also see
that he has a red book this is by Carl
Young And it deals with Shadow salves
and double sides similar to what Jack
has we can also see that he's wearing a
green tie with several lines across it
these are actually patterned to look the
same way that the maze does which is of
course a big location that pops up in
the movie Jack wears something green
throughout every scene early on in the
film however he later switches to Red
after having the dream about murdering
Danny and Wendy this could show a shift
in his mindset and red is of course a
color that pops up in key horror scenes
a Jack's home we meet the pair and we
can catch Wendy reading The Catcher in
the Rye this is a highly controversial
book and it basically centers around the
loss of Innocence the book has had a lot
of debates surrounding it and it was
even since it in school so I think
Kubrick put it in for a reason now in a
strange coincidence a month after this
movie's release Mark David Chapman
murdered John Lennon and he sat down and
read this whilst he wait for the police
I know Cuba couldn't have predicted this
but it's Eerie seeing this now and we
then meet Tony when Danny Lloyd
auditioned for the part of Tony he
actually came up with it then and
Kubrick loved it so much that he cast
him in the film in the book we learned
that it's his adult self and the clue is
that Danny's full name is Danny Anthony
Torrance back at Allman's office we also
get some dialogue that touches upon what
happened in the source material Jack
ended up attacking a student while still
worked as a teacher and thus he had to
seek employment elsewhere this could be
linked in with his alcoholism and it
also explains the rage that he busts out
later now after the interview scene we
get a very important moment that
foreshadows a lot of what's coming down
the line we see Dany bent over the
bathroom sink and slowly approached your
bath with a shower curtain pulled this
also foreshadows what to come in room
237 with a curtain also being pulled
over the bathroom net little side note
this room was recreated for the tv show
Hannibal along with the carpet in the
hotel it's one of the most referenced
things in cinema on the wall we can also
catch a sticker of Dopey from the Seven
Dwarfs after his vision this disappears
potentially signifying that Danny's no
longer Dopey when it comes to the hotel
he also gets nicknamed doc by dick
Halloran Doc is the wisest of the seven
dwarfs and this nickname could have been
chosen for a reason I don't think that
the sticker disappearing is an accident
and Kubrick was famous for layering his
films with details like this there are
theories that the way Dany is leaning
over here is meant to be similar to show
later on with the guy in the dog seat
many have stayed that this is
dissignified that Dany was abused by his
father and later we see Dany lying on a
bear pillow which is thought to also be
a nod to this the child psychologist
that comes to visit them probes Wendy
later on and she seems to suggest it but
it's important to bear in mind this only
appears in the longer versions of the
film that were released in the US
Kubrick actually cut out 23 minutes from
the movie for the UK's release and it's
difficult to discern what his actual
intentions for the film were I don't
subscribe to that theory and honestly I
don't really like thinking about when
watching the movie but I feel like I
have to touch upon it though because
it's such a popular Theory and it's
believed that the things that happen in
room 237 are actually carried out by
Jack to Danny when the room calls him in
the tennis ball rolls to him on the
floor and this is also the same ball
that Jack scene throwing throughout the
hotel I'm sure everyone watching this
also knows that when he sat down in the
hotel that we can see him reading a
Playgirl magazine later this one
specifically had an article about incest
which many have said ties into this
Theory again not really my
interpretation of it but I thought if I
didn't bring it up I'd be skipping over
one of the most common theories on the
film now Dany is of course lurking in a
mirror when this happens and it's
important to bear in mind that a mirror
appears in every scene that a ghost does
it's possible that these could reveal
the truth and be gateways to a mirror
world that we often overlook this could
be where the spirits inhabit and it
could also explain why Tony uses one to
write murder it of course comes out
backwards as red rum and this idea of it
being a mirror could be represented in
that on the road Jack tells Danny of the
donor party and the cannibalism They
carried out in order to stay alive this
will Shadows the impending isolation and
the family are going to be facing
another thing they're headed for a fun
trip there is Darkness to it now from
here we get some masterful editing by
Kubrick as we watch the exterior of the
hotel and then this transitions in the
shape of a ladder in the lobby not a
crazy detail just just a nice bit of
editing after a tour of the lounge we
cut to Danny who's in The Game's room at
this point he meets the twins for the
first time and this once more ties in
with the idea of mirrors kibrick
included a lot of symmetrical shots
throughout the movie and I think he was
hinting that everything has a double
side to it up in the top left we can
also catch a poster of a man's skiing
the way great shot though has had many
thinking that it makes his leg seem like
their ankle backwards this would be
similar to a Minotaur and with the maze
at the end there could be this tie to
ancient Greek mythology this idea of
doubles carries across to the next scene
as we see two girls that look extremely
similar passing behind the three next we
have the Hedge maze which wasn't in the
book and Kubrick had this created solely
for the movie in the source material
hedge animals came alive and this
appeared in the 1997 adaptation which
again less less said about that the
better now lastly we see the Gold Room
how he watches Wendy does a little dance
across the floor this is semi Jack does
later on mirroring the move that set up
here but then introduced to Dick finally
and he shows Wendy and Danny about the
hotel's kitchen think everyone at this
point knows the hell that Kubrick per
both Shelley de Valens Catman gorilla's
true answer and he had them doing
hundreds of takes which broke them
mentally carrillas would be on the verge
of tears when talking about the film and
so on the scenes held the Guinness World
Record for the amount of takes They
carried out his scene in the kitchen was
apparently shot 148 times the holding
the Guinness world record for the most
amount of takes now at this point we're
disorientated even more as dick enters
the freezer when they enter it we can
see an office to the side as they go
inside when they exit though things that
had just been in the scene before are no
longer there and though it's something
you might not notice your subconscious
will probably be thrown off are they
shown about the dry storage and Jack is
later locked there he's seemingly freed
by the ghosts and for many this breaks a
theory that it's all in their heads
however there is a possible explanation
for how he escaped if you want to keep
that theory in your mind when the three
leave the Frieza they pass a secondary
door and the position of this means that
it would be in the pantry somewhere this
Jack could use this to get out on his
own accord I've always been someone who
doesn't like when things are completely
spelled out and I do kind of like the
ambiguity you have for thinking the
ghost may not even be real dick then
looks after Dany and he feeds him ice
cream whilst telling him about The
Shining this scene signals the incoming
danger Danny's gonna have to face and
Kubrick has the shot set up so the
knives are above Danny's head pointing
down at him dick says that he used a
whole entire conversations in his head
with his grandma and this speaks to the
familial hereditary ability that The
Shining could have he also says
if someone Burns toast
well
maybe things that happen the other kind
of Chase is behind
it's just like pictures in a book candy
it isn't real this is why the girls have
to use Jack and why they manipulate him
throughout it could allowing Credence to
the fact that Jack was the one who heard
Danny in room 237 but with that room
being the hotel's heart and maybe why he
was able to harm him could also explain
why dick tells Dany not to go into room
237 because that could be the one place
Daddy can be harmed at this point we
could have the hotel empty all except
for the three members of the family who
follow Danny as he rides around the
hotel and this Steadicam movement as he
Glides is very similar to the shot setup
that we get when he's running through
the maze the son of The Wheels on the
floor and carpet are also repurposed
later on with the noise of them playing
into the score itself
foreign
[Music]
we see Jack in bed being brought
breakfast by Wendy on his T-shirt we can
see the word stubbington and this is the
high school that Jack taught at in the
book now from here we go to a typewriter
with a blank piece of paper Jack later
ends up constantly writing the words all
work and no play make Jack adult boy and
people have actually analyzed this sound
when we catch him typing and you can
hear him basically typing this phrase
out over and over again
foreign
[Music]
Ty and Danny then run into the maze with
a former chasing him and saying
this is very much foreshadowing the
chase that will happen later on with his
other parent running after him in the
maze at the end of the film back in the
hotel we see a cuddly toy in the floor
and Kubrick purposely put this here to
set up Dick's death which happens in the
same place jack also walks past the sofa
and if you look closely at it you can
actually see the baseball bats sticking
out that Wendy will later use Jack looks
down over the Maze and in an amazing bit
of superim position we can see Wendy and
Danny walking in it this was a model but
I think going from the could object to
them here is meant to hint at him
overlooking them there's also theories
that this is the moment where we switch
to the book story and that Jack is
simply typing away writing this book as
the rest of the events play out anyway
after this point we catch Jack typing
away in the Colorado Lounge he hides his
paper from Wendy because this would give
away that he's just been using Bots to
type out the same comment over and over
again also there's a couple of important
aspects of this scene and the first of
these is the urban book on the table
this contains newspaper clipping and the
reason Jack recognizes Dell but later on
is because he saw his photo amongst
these this scene also contains a
disappearing chair that many suspects
been put in to mess with our minds
Kubrick was Notorious for going on set
and messing with things in between takes
when this is the clearest example of
that happening in the movie over Jack
shall though we can spot a chair and
smaller table and this constantly
disappears and reappears whether this is
a continuity error or not we'll never
know this feels like something too
obvious for them to not pick up when
editing now from here we go to Jack
staring out looking like a nutcase guys
lost it but I bet he'd be having a great
time out there if they could get
internet to subscribe to the heavy
spoiler show new video every day you
never get bored but anyway the days are
done and we get a real sense of
isolation with each character being in
different parts of the hotel Wendy isn't
able to reach out at others with the
radio and with her we go to ullman's
office we can see the storm outside
beating down again highlighting the fact
that this is a real view behind behind
it even though it shouldn't exist now we
get a lot of weird creepy scenes such as
the TV one and then Danny and Jack
sitting in a room together Jack
Nicholson's performance is so unhinged
in the movie and like from the first
scene I was I was thinking Geisinger
anyway we then cut to Danny playing with
his toys on the infamous carpet almost
maze-like we see as the line leads
towards him that the tennis ball
perfectly rolls along well we're in the
next shot we can see that the line has
switched points to now being behind him
when we go back to him that Line's
completely gone in front of him almost
leaving him trapped in the pull of room
237 interestingly the bug originally had
the rumors being 217 but the hotel
owners asked them to change it because
they were worried no one would ever
bucket all the exterior shots of the
hotel are of the real-life Timberline
Lodge and being associated with a movie
about murder made them worry it could
cause issues missed a trick there though
mate I bet tons of people would have
loved to have booked a room there after
seeing just how popular the movies
become and next we cut to ending the
boiler room and in a black and white
photo above the fridge we can see two
twins probably gonna have to blur out
the entire wall above the desk as well
as there's tons of nude women in the
photos but when he just passes by as if
nothing's wrong and next we see Jack
slumped over his desk almost having a
nightmare where he kills Wendy and Danny
this ties in with the theory before and
some are suspected that the show's Jack
is using his powers of shining to
project his Consciousness into 237 but
when he runs over to him we can also see
a chair against the pillar to the left
but when Jack's on the floor this
completely disappears Danny walks in
with his shirt torn and at this point
Wendy suspects Jack did it and we then
catch Jack walking towards the girl room
along the way we can see there are
several mirrors and an important thing
that happens here is that Jackal lashes
out every time that he passes one this
is almost like the mirrors are
triggering him and he goes into the bar
and sits in front of a mirror we then
get a change of the camera angle so that
Jack's staring directly at us when he's
in fact fact looking in the mirror at
this point the bartender appears the
movie really starts to escalate moments
before Jack said he'd sell his soul for
a drink and this is when Lloyd shows up
Jack also says I like you Lloyd I always
like you you were always the best of
them and again this plays into the idea
that this is something that's always
happened and always will happen at this
point Wendy interrupts things and Jack
goes to 237 inside the room we meet a
woman and who else has gone to bed with
a 10 and woke up with a one my wife for
stars are you having that having that
an obviously can't show that scene but
there's something very hypnotic about it
with a score just drowning away in the
background and almost playing out in
slow motion in the book this woman was a
guest who ended her life in the bathtub
and she's very much a metaphor for the
hotel itself she seems beautiful on the
surface but once you get in close you
start to see the Decay and rot at the
center of it slowly everything starts
crashing down and we get rivers of blood
as Jack loses it at the idea of taking
Danny to a hospital he storms out the
room looking directly at the camera and
this unnerving forth wall break is
almost like he's looking at the hotel
and us who are watching him now from
here we get the girl room ball scene and
the person that Jack passes at the
doorway is the same one as the man that
later says
great party isn't it inside we also meet
dalbet and he spells Advocate over
Jack's jacket this looks like egg and
eggs actually an ingredient that's in
the drink nice little visual gag here
with Jack wiping his hand and his back
as a sign of contempt now Grady takes
him to the red bathroom and something
about this may throw you off beyond the
garish color scheme we know from the way
they enter this bathroom it's located
behind the bar however as we go further
into it we can see that there are
cubicles that stretch out past the
urinal the width of this means that if
it actually existed then it would be
over the bar itself so this once more is
an impossible room the red paint is
almost like blood and this is
potentially linking back to the elevator
scene now Delbert uses the n-word to
describe dick and the Rachel
undertonesier could link back to the
white man's burn line the ball's scenes
are very much a throwback to White
affluence and these Sinister undertones
with the racial comments could be
Kubrick showing how he thinks the
characters viewed minorities Delbert
tells Jack that he corrected his two
dollars after they attempted to set fire
to the hotel and this was likely the
location acting in self-defense they
were a threat to it and this had left
into action using their father to take
out the children dick makes his way to
Colorado and we catch Jack once more
typing away the room is also shown to be
symmetrical adding to the feeling that
the hotel has a double side to it who
follow dick as he makes his way out
there and the journey is long and
tedious I think it's purposely done this
way as well as we have a massive long
drawn out build up that settles us into
feeling like nothing is gonna happen
that's when Jack attacks from behind a
pillar and it comes out of nowhere
completely catching you off guard now
back in the room with Wendy and Danny we
can hear them watching Roadrunner
cartoons on TV
Maybe
this cartoon is of course about a coyote
trying to catch the Roadrunner which
could be foreshadowing the chase that
comes at the end we then get the
staircase scene which apparently had 127
takes some have said this was an
exaggeration but either way there were a
ton carried out and you can tell just
how exhausted Shelley Daval is the real
exhaustion here was the person who had
to type out at all work and no play for
400 times felt sorry for them because
they didn't have copy and paste back
then and Jack is then dragged into the
pantry and I love the little stumble he
does as he tries to get up he damaged
his ankle during the stairfall and for
the rest of the movie we watch his
elimse after his prey to me this is
Nicholson's most memorable performance
and watching him turn into a violent
psychopath that is arguably the best
thing he's done as when he discovers the
destroyed snow cat we see as a title
cards change from days to hours showing
how little time is left Jack is freed by
Delbert and from here we catch Danny in
a trans saying Red Rum which leads into
the of the infamous mirror scene this
then goes into another classic moment
which Jack chops down the door to the
bathroom riffing on Johnny Carson he
says here's Johnny
brick had never actually heard this
catchphrase before and thus he didn't
know it was related to the TV hosts so
they left it in it's probably more known
for being in this movie now rather than
belonging to Carson and it shows just
how much of an impact this scene has
[Music]
don't
yes Jackie
here's Jackie here's Johnny
[Music]
here's Danny this scene actually took
three days and sixty dollars to film as
the production team had ordered
Breakaway doors however Nicholson had
volunteered as a firefighter so he knew
the correct technique to use meaning
that the doors didn't take long to get
through this was actually almost shot
for shot the same as the scene in the
Phantom Carriage you should adds to
ready Rick on Reddit for putting this
together and the movie was
coincidentally released in 1921 which is
the air on the photo at the end Danny
runs through the kitchen and he ends up
hiding in a cabinet this actually ended
up inspiring long-term friend Steven
Spielberg to do something similar in the
kitchen scene that pops have been
Jurassic Park and then Jack chases his
son whilst Wendy runs through the hotel
we hear chance of the spirits making
this scene become even creepier
[Music]
here we get the dog costume scene and
this pause from the buck with someone in
one of these doing what we see here
don't know how they got around doing it
with the mask on but but moving on now
Wendy's Journey Through the hotel was
actually cut out of the UK version for
about 20 years of watching this movie
I'd never seen the skeleton scene and
honestly I feel like it should have been
left out the skeletons they don't look
good
um and it's not really what I think this
movie was going for amongst them though
we can see several people that popped up
in the Gold Room including Delbert Grady
serving drinks at the top of the table
when he then runs along a red Corridor
and we get the blood scene which so far
has only shown up in Visions outside we
see is Jack closes in on Danny but he
outsmarts his father to lead him astray
this is the best use of the Steadicam
for me with a Chase feeling almost like
what Jack running behind his son Dany
manages to escape with his mother Raz
Jack is stuck in there and we end with
him sitting down and panting a cubic was
known for doing jump cuts and this one
was most notably seen at the start of
2001 however I feel like this moment is
another of his best with this cutting to
the Frozen corpse of Jack in the morning
huge it out to depression Obsession on
Reddit for bothering out that this
expression here is the same one that he
has when he has his first drink the user
even plays the two moments over the top
of each other and we can see how
perfectly It lines up you then go to the
photograph and see Jack perhaps hitting
at the cycle of violence being something
that's ongoing we close out to midnight
the stars are new and this ends the
movie on a very haunting note anyway
that's all breaking in the film and I
hope you liked it add a blast going back
through the movie and I know there's so
much to unpack that we probably didn't
even touch upon because of that I'd love
to see you coming so make sure you drop
them below and let us know if there's
anything we missed or just talk about
your favorite detail and also love to
hear your thoughts on what you want us
to cover next so make sure you drop it
below if you want to be able to watch
them make sure you check out our
Brighton of Event Horizon which will be
linked on screen right here right now
obviously after this if not though I
understand because it's been a long
video and yeah I'll see you next time
you take care yourself I've been Paul
you've been the best next one bye